Come with me on a date night to coltora in Charleston.
Matt and I have been dying to try this place
since it's been nominated for a James Beard Award.
Coltora is known for creative twists on Filipino food,
so we were really excited to just be surprised.
Started with the arroz caldo,
which was spicy and umami,
like a hug in a bowl. They also tried one of their crudo dishes,
and I just love the presentation on this.
The pink glass with the pink tuna.
It was delicious. I'm a humongous noodle girl.
So when they said that they had a carbonara on the menu,
I was down. Look at that noodle pole.
Everything had a flavor of being familiar,
but also incredibly surprising.
Definitely make a reservation, though,
because dining room is small.
Let me know if you've checked it out.